iraq is fighting a two-pronged battle to
increase power supply the country is
trying to resolve power shortages but US
sanctions mean it must do so without the
help from neighboring Iran at 3,000
megawatts the beasts Maya plant south of
Baghdad is Iraq's biggest it's racing to
add capacity ahead of the summer heat
when demand soars and frequent power
cuts fuel public anger construction has
been delayed by the corona virus
pandemic just the latest in a series of
crises that have complicated the
government's efforts the challenge was
that hit us was the first was the
protests and in October last year in
2019 and then the that the fact that the
government was forced to resign that
made us lose a lot of executive
authority to move on continuing and
implementing or signing the necessary
contracts Iraq is also under increasing
pressure from the u.s. to wean itself
off of Iranian electricity and gas
imports which account for 25 percent of
its power supply during peak times on
Sunday the u.s. extended a sanctions
waiver that has been in place since 2018
allowing Iraq to continue importing
Iranian energy for another 30 days but
the shortening of the duration of
waivers has angered Baghdad the loss
would like to see as it's bullying or
threatening we need support instead we
need three to four years under normal
circumstances with the sufficient fund
and enough timeline and full executive
authority to deliver the needful and and
basically building up the capacity to
achieve that energy independence Iraq is
the world's fourth largest oil producer
but its gas capture capacity remains
limited this power plant relies entirely
on Iranian gas to generate electricity
if that gas can no longer be imported it
might need to use fuel instead which is
much more costly and
sufficient to avoid having to resort to
domestic supplies of diesel Iraq is
working on developing its capacity to
produce gas but in the short term
analysts say it has few options to
substitute Iranian gas imports thus far
Iraq throughout all these negotiations
that it's hard with with with its
neighbors and everybody has not been
offered a price for gas or a mechanism
for getting gas as fast as possible at a
price that is lower than Iran increasing
supply will only solve part of Iraq's
electricity problems proposals to remove
electricity subsidies so as to cover
production costs and regulate demand
have faced political opposition and over
half of supply is lost through poor
distribution and theft
with or without Iranian energy power
cuts are likely to remain a frequent
reality for many Iraqis Simona 14:00 al
Jazeera Baghdad